using bitcoin to buy clothes snacks even
the daily newspaper instead of us
dollars is now an option to the people
in el salvador as the country becomes
the first in the world to adopt the
volatile crypto as its national currency
it's a big test for bitcoin in the real
world and for salvadorans to get them
started the government is giving thirty
dollars to people who sign up to an
e-wallet called shiva which allows for
the automatic conversion of dollars to
bitcoin and vice versa
on day one a number of technical issues
were reported in the country with the
app
while some businesses welcomed this
crypto experiment 80 of salvadorans have
little or no confidence in bitcoin and
some have opposed the move
one big reason is because people don't
want their wages to be denominated in
bitcoin it's related to the sharp
fluctuations in value that bitcoin has
also a lot of people think that software
is not really prepared for this type of
adoption a lot of people don't have
smartphones and if they do they don't
have data plans
and i worked really hard and i lived
there and i got to know the community
and i made friends that i hope will be
at my wedding someday
and uh so with all that being said i'd
like to invite
el salvador's president announced the
plan in june making a surprise
appearance via video link at a bitcoin
conference being held in miami in the
short term this will generate jobs and
help provide financial inclusion to
thousands outside the formal economy
president bukele has said that adapting
bitcoin will among other things attract
foreign investment and foster cheaper
financial services but it also risks
wrecking el salvador's 26 billion dollar
economy
bitcoin is known for its big swings with
huge sell-offs that can be triggered by
a tweet and its decentralized system
opens the doors to anonymous and illicit
transactions like money laundering or
ransom payments economists say
the government's plan has parked
protests in the impoverished central
american nation
the law was
passed in a matter of hours without
discussion with stakeholders uh
the private sector was never consulted
the same goes for labor unions or other
segments of society so it was in a way
imposed and this comes at a time when el
salvador is facing some
economic headwinds they have a very
significant budget deficit they are in
talks with the international monetary
fund to get a financial aid package of
1.3 billion
el salvador's finance minister said he
doesn't expect bitcoin's volatility to
pose a problem and that the instant
convertibility of bitcoin to dollars by
achievable is likely to be sufficient
financial institutions will also be
required to alert customers of bitcoin's
volatility
bitcoin is currently trading at around
50 000
each
bitcoin's adoption as legal tender in el
salvador is unprecedented and this
experiment is going to be closely
monitored by crypto advocates global
financial institutions and governments
around the world to see how it works how
effective it is and what the
consequences could be